make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so picking up with deceased part
three this was actually kind of sad we
talked about this in our injustice
videos right and we even talked about in
the first the first video or so of of
deceased that when it comes to Tom
Taylor as a writer
while his stories can be exceedingly
dark Tom Taylor is very very good at
drawing out the human element of
characters as well this is why I love
Alex Ross art so much to kind of go off
on a tangent for a second you look at
like the Alex Ross drawing of like the
Justice League or like the JSA or
something like that and it almost makes
you nostalgic for an era of comics that
none of us are really part of when like
there were good guys and bad guys and
like that was it but it was more like
the people behind the characters it's
why the world's greatest superheroes I
think is the greatest comic book
miniseries of all time and this picks up
essentially with Alfred just kind of
saying his goodbyes to some of the bat
family right so it's like Tim Drake and
to Batman and to Dick Grayson because
all three of them are dead and whenever
we read stories like this when
characters die you know depending on how
attached we are there's always like that
one part of us that would that kind of
wishes they were still there right like
the kind of kind of holds out hope that
like they'll come back you know and it's
kind of interesting because it's like
okay well maybe we missed something
maybe they're not really dead you know
maybe they're just like recovering or
like Batman's healing or something but
like something has to happen that they
come back and Tom Taylor just kind of
seems to put all this indication of like
no they're gone
Alfre basically takes you know the the
batwing and like leaves but the cool
thing about this and one the reasons why
I like that so much is because this puts
off the indication and it really shows
how bleak things are that like heroes
are dying left and right and they're not
coming back and it's kind of the cool
thing because well this is only really
six issues long just from what I've seen
so far I feel like it could be longer I
mean anything more than nine I think you
would stretch on too much but from what
we saw with like what is it Batman the
white knight like six-issue miniseries
can lead into something better which is
what we're getting right we're getting a
sequel to the to the white knight this
looks really really awesome and so
switching over to Harley Quinn like it's
kind of a bit of a moment for her right
I mean when it comes to Harley and DC
Comics this is one of the things that
I've always kind of struggled with with
her characters when it comes to Harley
in DC Comics when she first popped up
she was basically kind of a holdover
from Batman the Animated Series right
that's where she originally appeared
that's where she got her debut and there
wasn't really a whole lot of development
there it wasn't until a few years went
by the DC sauna is sort of finally
focusing and building on Harley and then
of course later on added her to the
Suicide Squad and different things like
that but the idea behind this is that
her character has always
for a long time sort of existed under
the shadow of the Joker that's what she
was best known for but for the for her
character inside the comics she's under
the shadow of Joker right like he's the
guy who taunts her he's the guy that
makes her life a living hell and the guy
she always goes back to you and so where
she's always kind of tried to make an
escape in this one we get a kind of
finality here right I mean the Joker is
is is zombified right um he's a
zombified version the Joker he's a
zombie Harley Quinn like grabs a shotgun
and like blows him in half right just
like shoots him and kills him for at
least you know seems to kill him now one
of the things that that haven't really
been it hasn't really been established
here by Tom Taylor at least not outright
specifically is that if a person has
kind of turned into one of these
quote-unquote zombies which he's kind of
sated they're not really zombies but
they basically are if a person is turned
into a zombie and then it turned like
they are killed by traditional means can
they come back and I don't think that's
explicitly been stated yet right let me
know a person can be turned into a
zombie but that but there's no
indication they could actually come back
from that if they've been killed but
still like it at the moment right now
the Joker is just kind of shot and
killed and that seems to be the end of
that and then Harley's met by the birds
of prey right so like Huntress and
Catwoman and bat woman and Batgirl
so basically like a majority of the
superhero humidity are now being turned
into these zombie things and that's why
I say it's so cool
it's because everybody's back really
seems to be up against the wall it's the
end times right like things are falling
apart it almost kind of seems like a
fast-tracked version of injustice right
I mean injustice you know things pop off
the Joker kills or really tricked
Superman into killing Lois and their
unborn child a bomb gets blown up or you
know as detonated it wipes out
metropolis and then over the course of
like an entire year or really two years
depending on how you want to look at it
Superman goes from like this guy who was
a superhero to like a a full-on villain
and so it's kind of a cool thing because
you look at that and it's like
fast-tracked right it's like things are
falling apart things are basically
breaking apart exceedingly fast but it
works because if this were to happen and
if some kind of zombie plague were to
manifest and be spread through digital
information then it would happen this
fast right I mean as often people are on
their phones surfing the web looking at
YouTube videos different things like
that people are constantly wired and and
connected and so if there if there were
some kind of digital virus they could
convert people into like these monstrous
zombie things it would happen like that
that the world would be conquered within
a day and a half
only rural villages and towns would be
the ones would be the last affected
because they're really more disconnected
than than like major metropolitan areas
but again it's a cool thing and so
switching over to Damian this is a part
of him that we usually never get to see
when you have Damian like eats basic
facing the fact that like his father's
dead and for Damian Wayne historically
speaking as a character he's almost
seemed disconnected from his own
humanity right I mean he was basically
conceived by Talia al Ghul and basically
like a pretty screwed up scenario with
Batman and then in turn like raised
among the the League of Assassins and
then basically taught to be like this /
digis killer right like the human
element was never really part of it he
was just taught to kill and it wasn't
until he was brought to Batman and
raised by Bruce that Bruce tried to
instill that human element in him right
it's the nature of the progression of
his character going from what was
essentially a killing machine to
becoming a killing machine who's also
human and so because of that because we
never really get to see this kind of
moment in him it's actually pretty
touching because Jonathan sits down with
him and where Damian Wayne doesn't want
to talk Jonathas response is okay well
then I'll go ahead and just sit here so
that you don't have to be alone it's a
very important thing and on the surface
it kind of seems like okay well that's
interesting this is probably one of the
most important displays of friendship
that Jonathan's ever shown to Damian and
the reason why is because sometimes it's
not all about just being there and like
giving the right answers all the time
and sitting it's saying everything you
need to say they just make a person feel
better
sometimes it's just being there like the
knowledge of you being there is enough
and that's all they need all they need
is to know that you're there and that's
that's it that's that's the only comfort
they need everything else they can deal
with internally and when the time comes
when they're ready to talk they will
it's a very important life lesson that I
think not a few people not enough people
learned being there is important that's
the most important thing so again you
know you have Superman you have Lois who
actually stay hands off the same thing
with with Oliver Queen and with Dinah
Lance they kind of stay hands off and
they're like we'll just leave them there
and we'll just let them be friends and
whatever happens happens it's a really
really cool moment but Superman's
response is also kind of focusing on
other things because he kind of keeps
mulling over into himself you know how
Damien's feeling Damian just lost his
dad and then it clicks
Superman's responses I have to go home I
have to go to Smallville and initially
it's kind of like okay you know Lois is
like okay I understand you have to do
that but Superman is kind of like okay
what what we need to do is create a safe
space for you guys and this is the this
is one of the coolest moments in the
story because when this happened
Superman uses his x-ray vision he looks
throughout the entirety of the Daily
Planet and he has to differentiate
between who's infected and who's not and
what he says here is that those who are
infected cannot be brought back and so
he has to stop looking at them like
they're human beings and look at them
strictly as the enemy and that's a
crushing thing for Superman to have to
do right because he's the guy who always
sees the best in things who always sees
hope
Superman embodies hook and to suddenly
thrust himself into a position where he
has to look at people and say there is
no hope is devastating there are people
he's worked with for years you know
Jimmy and Jimmy Olsen like Perry White
they're family
and so with that being the case it's
literally him having to eliminate his
own family members because there's no
way to save them it's it's an absolutely
devastating role to have to take on the
hardest part of this whole situation is
separating himself from his own humanity
it's the hardest thing to do and it's so
cool to see it done that way right I
mean it's things like this he's kind of
cool introspective deconstructive
stories with Superman in them that make
him more interesting right I mean
because Superman is easily original
superhero he flies he punches that's not
interesting what makes it interesting is
when you focus on him as a character in
these scenarios where he has to kind of
cast aside everything he's known and
become something different even if only
for a brief amount of time as it's a
cool little moment here because then you
switch over to Atlantis and you've got
Mara and then you've got Darth learning
how to use his powers as tempest or at
least controlling them in a more finite
level and Mara being the one to teach
him right but remember Atlantis is for
the most part isolated from the surface
world and aside from Aquaman neo
realizes it like the surface is going to
pot and we haven't see what he's been
doing nobody else in Atlantis knows
what's going on there's no reason for
them to be concerned but it's suddenly
in the midst of all this the water
starts turning dark and for me it was it
was kind of confusing for us I don't
like why in the world is the water
turning dark like you know and it was
kind of wild because when that happened
like you literally find out that what
Aquaman's been doing is attacking and
killing everyone not only that like
Aquaman presumably has been attacking
like animal sharks and things like that
because they're now consuming people
either that or Aquaman is sending out
like subtle commands to the shark saying
like kill everyone so like it could be
one of the other but literally like this
is all just blood in the water
and that's what Maher says like stay
away from the blood like do not make
contact with the blood but for Garth
it's too late
and so with Mary using her powers to
essentially control water she makes her
escape and it's actually kind of a cool
little thing because what she could do
here it's create a kind of safe pocket
around herself everywhere she goes but
remember Mira's powers can be mentally
exhausting she's gonna have to make her
way to the surface she's gonna have to
seek out what's left of the superheroes
but when she gets to the surface then
she's gonna realize how dire things are
that the world is essentially over as it
was kind of cool because the Superman
making his way one of the things he says
is like like for him as a hero his job
is to be there for as many people as he
can but the problem he faces right now
is that like everyone needs him and so
of course he comes across black
lightning it comes across yet comes
across Jefferson Pierce Jefferson Pierce
is actually kind of cool
you never really
see him that much you like these
crossover events I mean I think it's
really he's more pronounced now than he
has been before because he's got his own
show it was Jefferson Pierce is kind of
interesting it's kind of a combination
of like like innate abilities are not
really innate abilities but like
abilities unto himself as well as using
like some kind of magic and mysticism to
create like black lightning but still
it's kind of cool with this whole thing
because when he shows up like it's
basically him fighting fighting Clayface
because Clayface is infected and it's
like turning in like this giant tentacle
monster like attacking everything in
sight we only see Jeffers and Pierce for
a short amount of time but it is kind of
cool because you get to see they're like
hey look there's some guys here one of
the things that I dig about this is that
this almost kind of feels like a movie
it's an interesting little scenario but
when he gets back home to Smallville of
course he's met by his mother Martha and
she's like your father's inside I hit
him over the head something's wrong with
him and then of course when Superman
gets in there it turns out that his
father's infected now this kind of makes
sense the idea of Jonathan of Jonathan
Kent dying it's part and parcel to his
character right I mean it's what happens
with him and so when you have this
scenario and for where like Superman
gets home and like his father's infected
it's one of the most touching moments in
the story because usually whenever
Jonathan Kent died it was circumstances
outside of Superman's control right like
either he wasn't there or it was
something that he couldn't have helped
whatever the case was whether it was in
like the Man of Steel movie where he
gets whisked away by a tornado and which
of course is a result of him making one
of the dumbest decisions ever like hey
son like rescue them and in rescue me
because you're super fast and you can
easily do it no just stay there and
don't save me because the world doesn't
need to know you exist okay I'm pretty
sure that if Superman was like hey look
guys I really had to do this I had to
rescue my dad please just don't tell
anybody who I am and it would be like
yeah man we understand dude like it's
cool I'm pretty sure they wouldn't run
off to the paper and say hey man there's
this guy who can fly in in like
Smallville uh you guys should definitely
write a report about him it was it was
clearly like terrible writing on behalf
of Zack Snyder which is what he usually
does but but nonetheless like his father
normally dies right and so like in those
circumstances where it's outside
Superman's control and this circumstance
it is like Superman literally has to put
his the aput is humanity aside in the
most extreme scenario ever and say okay
like my father's here I'm going to leave
him here you would expect like what I
would have expected is that he would
have killed him I know a lot of people
would have disagreed with that and a lot
of people would have said no that's dumb
that's stupid you know yeah out of so on
and so forth I think it would've been
awesome because it would have been
really one of these moments that really
kind of doesn't really snap Superman but
really shows how dire things are the
Superman has to kill his own pops but
leaving
Smallville and leaving him there it kind
of you know leaving him confined down in
there unless he has a strength to break
out which he doesn't Superman basically
sealed a close with us with his heat
vision it kind of works because assuming
that he didn't find a way out then he
would just be kind of stuck down there
forever but if he did find a way out
well then there go Smallville like
everybody in Smallville is gonna be a be
infected so potentially Superman's
doomed his entire hometown assuming they
weren't really dead already
but it's kind of a cool thing it's a
it's a it's a cool moment like this
story's awesome and I think it's a lot
better than people are giving it
crediting it credit for it but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come as explained make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
you